very much for coming here I don't do
interviews of any circle Jeremy Corbyn
has long had a tricky relationship with
the media today it was all smiles as he
called for radical reform of the
industry when it comes to news and
current affairs were just so absolutely
vital and essential for a democratic
society
I believe our media in many cases is
failing telling an audience of TV
professionals the issues of trust and
fake news can't be ignored his solution
to tax tech giants like Google Amazon
and Facebook to pay for more
investigative Public Interest journalism
one solution to funding Public Interest
media could be by tapping up the digital
monopolies that profit from every search
every share and every like that we make
on our computers or smartphones the
Labour leader has in the past criticized
leading tech firms over tax avoidance
and data misuse and now he's going even
further this is just another in a long
line of proposals to tax tech companies
there is a wider question here though
about is it right for private companies
to be funding such crucial public work
and that really is the cornerstone of
our democracy
the growing competition from streaming
services like Netflix was addressed with
proposals of a digital license fee paid
for by big tech companies and internet
providers enabling the BBC to compete
more effectively and also to reduce
costs for poorer householders one of the
most divisive parts of the speech
concerned the BBC Jeremy Corbyn called
for information about the social class
of anyone who creates content for the
corporation to be published in a bid to
improve diversity and there was a
recognition from industry exacts that
they do need to improve in this area to
embrace diversity in all its forms if
you're working in television then
particularly at the BBC everyone pays
their licence me you should be
reflecting the nation and if you're
coming from a very narrow viewpoint in
quite a elitist viewpoint how are we
going to get the sort of content that
should appeal to the masses should
embrace different communities so we
appear to have somewhat of a conundrum a
politician famous for dodging the media
seemingly now riding to their rescue
Lucy got a Sky News